hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the escape
which is another game that you guys
suggested for me hello rain
goodbye rain alright this is made by the
Unreal development kit ignore all that
this is a horror game made with horror
stuff and boy howdy does that sound
familiar anyway
I like games that are made on the Unreal
development kit but well there are a lot
of sounds going on are you gonna build
up to something or you just go throw
sounds heavy these trees they look oddly
familiar hmm hmm some something's going
on
not sure what though hello did I just
burp and go up a few inches oh I didn't
burp you know what I mean a half a mo
what is going on here this doesn't seem
right
there's something bout an alien I saw on
the page not sure if I'm an alien or I'm
running away from an alien or there's an
alien that crash-landed here that I'm
trying to rescue hello what are you I
found a mini key I found a gate key
hi alien are you somewhere thingy mabh
are
whoa oh I thought those were eyes for a
second there I was like wait a minute
so I'm now right okay found a gate how
do I get to the other side I'm already
so confused I don't even know what I'm
doing I don't have the escape key well
what the hell this is awfully strange
it's kind of the collection mechanic but
at the same time I'm so utterly confused
and I'm just getting bashed by sounds
okay can I use the gate key on this gate
mm maybe oh come on
where this building come from I must be
going the wrong way
Oh Oh buildings a few inches away what
is that what what is that is that an
alien foot you can't fool me I see you
alien foot they can't fool me I am too
smart this game so confusing I can't say
that it's exactly well-made but I mean
it's made hello aha the gate key
excellent I mean not a lot of Polish
obviously with all the repetitive trees
and stuff but it's better put together
than 90% of the games I played like I'll
give it the benefit of the doubt for now
and just wait until something pops out
of me
found mini key to found room key found
nothing new stained bed sheets okay well
that was something
what's over here some sort of courtyard
still waiting for some sort of a threat
to pop up mini key three still don't
want the mini keys are for do I combine
them all into some conglomerate big key
a horrifying key unlike any other
maybe I don't know hello
oh I opened the door Wow
alright then you're gonna be like that
and I'm not gonna talk nice about you
what was the point of coming in here oh
here we go
bulk head key don't call my head bulky
I just haven't happened and everybody
got jokes not worth going for I'm not
funny enough as it is
might as well not ruin it I don't have
the main key the me I can't even barely
see that door whatever right then where
do I go I got a bulkhead key but where's
the bulkhead door what is the bulkhead
door anyway I'm so confused nothing
makes sense why am I here you didn't
give me any rhyme or reason you're just
throwing things in front of me hey
what's that up in the sky was that an
alien who's you're an alien up in the
sky probably oh I just for the first
time ever i noticed that i have a
minimap up in the corner there I swear I
did not even notice that that was there
oh hello
oh no a that's a front door doc well
what to hell I this the bulkhead yes
maybe
wait is that a trap that looks like the
shadow of an alien of some sort
oh yes it would nothing hahaha what the
heck what the heck what is going on
what's good if this is going into the
comically bad realm of gaming which is
just fine with me because it's just as
funny haha I mean that's all about what
this game is all about just being funny
right for you guys add to it really
matters
okay nothing okay nothing hmm a whole
lot of nothing and it did
and is something gonna pop out at me
again oh man it's like they use some
sort of default interface for some
sci-fi game found mini key for can I
combine them into a main key maybe yeah
I got that gate I'm guessing that open
the gate that was locked before so that
I can now go this way maybe hello nope
not that way
hello yes thank you all right another
quo hello you might have discovered the
statues creeped me out more than
anything else
well whatever main key yes I got it
well nothing's gonna happen with those
statues really you couldn't have done
something like make them turn towards me
follow me a bit maybe I'd be too much
trouble what what what what
I heard a noise you got to do something
about it mmm
hi-yah that's not exactly scary sure
it's startling but not scary come on you
can do better than that
or maybe you can't I have no idea and
the way I got the main key so upstairs
we go to the main floor gonna get it in
gonna get it in and out in and up and
out and over and around that was
obviously that alien that I saw in the
ground there hi
like I said not scary startling
startling is very different from scary
got to get it in it press e to use me to
keep one committee key
whoa what what was that someone object
to me opening me what are these anyway
pods that contain aliens I don't have
the master key but I didn't have that
before oh wait here we go oh but there
was max key yay
I'm using it well what that oh hello
hi it's the statues again oh hi how's it
going there buddy doing okay good yeah
move out of the way that's what I
thought
okay dramatic much what did that mean
can I just scoot the swag and scoot very
slowly forward okay I found the Escape
key which means that I can go back to
the escape area ya ya ya ya ya ya ya ya
ya loud noise is very very spooky oh
yeah I'm quaking in my boots just I'm
totally scared couldn't be more scared
right now they're really trying you know
if something was actually threatening me
if I didn't totally know that absolutely
nothing here can kill me I might be a
little bit concerned but obviously
obviously you have mistaken unless there
is somebody I don't know if there is
some behind me I would be much more
concerned but as far as it is there is
nothing escape oh my god oh not even a
trick it's really I really got to escape
to wow this guy doesn't know her at all
oh I'm actually now I'm not joking that
was pretty bad that was like all the
things you don't do in a horror game so
uh whoever suggested that to me you
should know better you should know
better than that okay you see so you see
you can't just throw loud noises and
fast movements into a game and call it a
horror game it's not it doesn't work
that way
it doesn't it's not scary unless you
create an atmosphere for it and that's
what's most important everything things
have to make sense it needs to be
grounded you know you can have poor
graphics even like seven days it was
scary because it had some semblance of
normalcy that loud things to then go
wrong but this it was wrong from the
start
every tree looked exactly the same
everything was the same they didn't even
try to add variety to it
there was no direction no reason for me
to be there and therefore no reason for
me to be scared you know there was no
threat the aliens made no sense when
they were popping out and they were just
popping out making loud noise
sure I got startled but I was never
scared so there's a lot of things wrong
with this game and I don't mean to be
rude or anything but that's just the way
it goes sometimes yeah just live and
learn
that's my criticism take it for what it
is so thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos
that I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video bye building's
beacons buildings are not really
duh
thanks again
as you can tell it as I click
because it's simple inside
bug
like this sounded like something
breathing down my